>> Sean: SLEEPY CRAZY CRAZY
UNCLE JOE BIDEN.
BIGGEST UP ON IT RIGHT NOW
CONTINUES TO BE HIMSELF.
THE SO-CALLED DEMOCRATIC FRONT
RUNNERS STILL MAKING GAFFE AFTER
GAS AFTER GAS, BLUNDER AFTER
BLUNDER, GETTING WORSE BY THE
DAY.
IF I'M DONALD TRUMP I'M THINKING
MAYBE I WANT THIS GUY TO GET THE
NOMINATION BECAUSE DURING A
RECENT CAMPAIGN AGAIN, UNCLE
JACK JOE APPARENTLY DIDN'T EVEN
REMEMBER WHAT YEAR HE WAS THE
VICE PRESIDENT.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE TRAGEDY
IN PARKLAND, FLORIDA, IN 2018.
THE SHOOTING WHICH OCCURRED A
YEAR AFTER HE LEFT OFFICE.
THIS IS WHAT HE THOUGHT ABOUT
IT.
>> I WATCH WHAT HAPPENED WHEN
THE KIDS FROM PARKLAND MARCHED
UP TO ME AND I MET WITH THEM AND
THEN THEY WENT OFF BUT ON THE
HILL TO GOING OUT TO THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS BUT ALL THOSE
CONGRESS PEOPLE LIKE I'M NOT
HERE, MY DEAR, DON'T TELL THEM
I'M AROUND.
THEY ARE AFRAID OF IT.
THEY SHOULD BE EXPOSED.
>> Sean: DOESN'T STOP THERE.
BIDEN IS STUMBLING OVER HIS
WORDS AT ALMOST EVERY EVENT.
HERE'S A SMALL LITTLE SAMPLE
FROM IOWA.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT CRAZY UNCLE
JOE NOW.
>> WE ARE.
WE CHOOSE UNITY OVER DIVISION.
WE CHOOSE SCIENCE OVER FICTION.
WE CHOOSE TRUTH OVER FACTS AND
>> THE WORDS THAT STUNG THE
NATION, I WOULD ARGUE, I KNOW,
SHOCK THE WORLD.
A NATIONAL LEADER SPOKE ABOUT
IT.
PEOPLE LIKE MARGARET THATCHER --
COOKSEY'S INCOME YOU HAVE PEOPLE
LIKE THE FORMER CHAIRMAN AND
LEADER OF THE PARTY IN GERMANY,
YOU HAVE ALAN MARKEL.
>> WE HAD THIS NOTION THAT
SOMEHOW IF YOU ARE POOR, YOU
CANNOT DO IT.
POOR KIDS ARE JUST AS BRAVE AND
JUST AS TALENTED AS WHITE KIDS.
>> Sean: POOR KIDS ARE JUST AS
BRIGHT AS WHITE KIDS AND HE WAS
IN VICE PRESIDENT DURING THE
PARKLAND SHOOTING AND HE SAID WE
CHOOSE TRUTH OVER FACTS AND
PRIME MINISTER THATCHER HAS BEEN
GONE A LONG TIME.
DIDN'T WE TELL YOU THIS WOULD
HAPPEN?
BY NOON WOULD BE SPINNING IN A
MILLION DIRECTIONS?
UNABLE TO STAY ON MESSAGE.
HIS TEAM IS RUNNING SCARED.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO AT
THIS POINT.
AND PUTTING HIS CAMPAIGN AND
NONSTOP DAMAGE CONTROL, YOU
CAN'T WORK IT IN THE
DUNKIN' DONUTS AND 7-ELEVEN
UNLESS YOU'VE GOT A SLIGHT
INDIAN ACCENT.
AND THEN HE SAID ABOUT
BARACK OBAMA, HE'S CLEAN AND
ARTICULATE.
THIS IS THE FIRST
AFRICAN-AMERICAN.
THIS IS STORYBOOK MAN.
AND OF COURSE HE WANTS TO TAKE
DONALD TRUMP BEHIND THE SCHOOL.
BIDEN CAN TO RUN ON THE OBAMA
BIDEN FAILED TO RECORD EITHER.
BECAUSE NOT ONLY IS THAT A
RECORD OF FAILURE, LET'S SEE,
13 MILLION MORE AMERICANS ON
FOOD STAMPS, A MILLION MORE IN
POVERTY, LOWEST LABOR
PARTICIPATION SINCE THE 70s,
WORSE RECOVERY SINCE THE 40s.
DONALD TRUMP, THE BEST
EMPLOYMENT SITUATION SINCE 1969.
I KNOW, I WAS EIGHT YEARS OLD,
THE METS WON THE WORLD SERIES.
I COULD TELL YOU LITTLE ONE
APPEARED NOT ONLY THAT, RECORD
LOW UNEMPLOYMENT
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANIC-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS, WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE, AND YOUTH
UNEMPLOYMENT HERE THAT DIDN'T
HAPPEN IN THE OBAMA BIDEN YEARS.
THAT HAPPENED UNDER TRUNK YEARS.
AFTER THE TAXES, AFTER MASSIVE
DEREGULATION, AFTER ENTICING
BUSINESSES TO INVEST IN AMERICA
AGAIN, ENERGY AND INDEPENDENT
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 75 YEARS
AND IF THEY ARE ENERGY COMPANIES
TRAINING TRUCK DRIVERS TO DRIVE
TRUCKS AND THEN STARTING TO PAY
80 GRAND A YEAR.
THIS WILL RAISE THE STANDARD OF
LIVING OF EVERY AMERICAN AND
WE'VE GOT GOLD UNDER OUR FEET IN
EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN CAN
BENEFIT.
UNLESS OF COURSE, WE GET BIDEN'S
VERSION OF THE NEW GREEN DEAL.
AND IF NOT ENOUGH, BY THE WAY,
THEY WANT OPEN BORDERS.
THEY WANT TRILLIONS OF NEW
ENTITLEMENTS PAY THEY WANT TO
GET RID OF THE COMBUSTION
ENGINE, OIL, GAS, CLOTHES,
PLANES.
THAT WILL TAKE THE COUNTRY INTO
POVERTY ALMOST INSTANTANEOUSLY.
AND BIDEN CAN'T RUN ON HIS OWN
SENATE RECORD EITHER.
HE WAS AGAINST INTEGRATION, HE
WANTED MORE SEGREGATION, HE WANE
WANTED MORE SEGREGATION, HE WAND
CREDITORS ON OUR STREETS.
REMEMBER THAT PARTICULAR?
AND EVEN RAISE THE FORMAL
KLANSMAN, ROBERT KKK BYRD
CALLING HIM A GREAT FRIEND OF
HIS AT HIS FUNERAL.
IMAGINE IF JOHN TRUMPED IT UP.
NOW, IT'S WHAT YOU COULD SEE
BIDEN CONTINUING TO WEAPONIZED'S
IDENTITY POLITICS.
REMEMBER, WE WILL PUT YOU ALL
BACK IN CHAINS.
TRYING TO HIDE FROM HIS OWN
DISTURBING POLITICAL PAST AND OF
COURSE, THAT'S NOTHING NEW FOR
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HERE'S A GLIMPSE OF THE SICK, BY
THE WAY, THIS USED TO BE EVERY
TWO AND FOR YEARS TO COME NOW